the house Ways and Means Committee voted
along party lines Tuesday to make six
years of former president Donald Trump's
tax returns public
there being 24 eyes and 16 knows the
motion to submit the committee report to
the house is agreed to and the documents
are ordered reported to the house Trump
didn't voluntarily releases tax returns
and had fought in court to block the
Internal Revenue Service from handing
them over the IRS hasn't completed the
Trump's audits for any of those years
documents released by the committee show
Donald Trump and Melania Trump reported
negative income in four of the six years
from 2015 through 2020.
for 2018 and 2019 the trumps reported
adjusted gross income of 24.3 million
dollars and 4.4 million dollars
respectively
all years combined documents show their
adjusted gross income was negative 53.2
million dollars during that period
the trumps paid some form of federal
taxes every year but reported income tax
liability of 750 or less and three of
those six years
a spokesman for Trump on Tuesday night
called approving the release the tax
returns a quote unprecedented leak by
lame duck Democrats and House
Republicans said the action sets a
dangerous precedent after nearly half a
century the political enemies list is
back in Washington D.C and we worry this
will unleash a cycle of political
retribution in Congress
Democrats said that the full release was
necessary for public transparency a full
set of Trump's tax documents was
expected to become public in the coming
days